bonjour à m mes chers collègues bonjour
à tous nous avons le grand plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui nos trois plus
grands énergéticiens pour échanger sur
la crise énergétique que nous traversons
actuellement que l'on peut je crois
qualifié de grave c'est une première au
parlement donc je tiens à vous remercier
tous les trois d'avoir accepté cet
exercice inédit madame mcgregor
directrice générale d' angie monsieur
puyané président directeur général de
total et monsieur marc benayoun en
charge du pôle clients service et
territoires de zdf vous avez publié tous
les trois il y a quelques semaines une
tribune intitulée le prix de l'énergie
menacent notre cohésion vous y rappeler
votre engagement à préparer l'hiver
prochain cet engagement passe selon
cette tribune par une diversification
des approvisionnements
un remplissage déstockage des
importations de gaz naturel liquéfié on
en reparlera je pense dans la loi qui
arrivent et une remise en fonction des
installations vous zappez aussi nos
concitoyens à agir là dedans pour un
grand programme d'efficacité énergétique
et une chasse au gaspi façon crise du
pétrole il ya quelques décennies vous
souhaitez le renforcement de la
solidarité européenne vous rappeler
enfin votre engagement en faveur de la
teinte de la neutralité carbone les
préoccupations que vous relevez dans
votre tribune nous les partageons ici
puisque dès le 24 février le jour de la
guerre russe en ukraine nous avons
adopté à l'unanimité un rapport sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement quelques
jours plus tard nous vous avons nous
avons proposé cinq mesures d'urgence
d'urgence pardon pour sortir de la
dépendance au gaz russe parmi lesquels
la révision du principe du coût marginal
l'accélération des projets de biogaz en
attente par exemple le 15 mars dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne avec des
parlementaires issus de 27 états membres
nous avons fait adopter des conclusions
en faveur d'une sortie de la dépendance
aux importations russes d'hydrocarbures
mais aussi de métaux critiques enfin le
30 mars l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie aie venu ici nous présenter
ses préconisations pour faire face à la
crise en matière de gaz et de pétrole
c'est dire si nous sommes attentifs à
ces questions mais aussi actif a donné
des recommandations
c'est donc la responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics mais aussi la vôtre de
faire en sorte que les français puissent
cet hiver se chauffer se déplacer et
travailler dans des conditions
acceptables par tous dans ce contexte je
souhaiterais donc vous poser plusieurs
questions à tous les trois tout d'abord
quel est précisément pour vous l'impact
de la guerre russe en ukraine sur votre
activité la presse parle parfois d'un
nouveau choc pétrolier d'une économie de
guerre est ce que vous partagez cette
analyse sommes nous prêts sur le plan de
l'offre pour l'hiver prochain et les
suivants le gouvernement a récemment
dévoilé un projet doit son pouvoir
d'achat dont un volet consacré la
souveraineté énergétique
ce volet vous semble-t-il suffisant ou
doit-on faire plus pour développer de
nouveaux projets renouvelables voire de
projets nucléaires à plus long terme
j'ai évidemment des questions sur votre
appel à une mobilisation citoyenne
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie a
appelé devant nous à réduire le niveau
de chauffage des logements d'un degré où
la vitesse de circulation de 10 km heure
ces pistes sont elles prometteuse quels
secteurs que les équipements qu'elle
pratique nécessite d'après vous de faire
l'objet d'une attention spécifique
la question la plus difficile au moins à
court terme est celle de la conciliation
entre la sécurité d'approvisionnement et
la neutralité carbone lorsque l'on voit
que le gouvernement souhaite revenir sur
l'arrêt de quatre centrales à charbon
alors qu'il a mené à bien celui de la
fermeture de deux réacteurs de la
centrale de fessenheim
n'avons nous pas apprendre beaucoup de
ce sujet en matière d'anticipation si
oui quels sont vos préconisations pour
la future loi quinquennale et de
programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie enfin dans quelle voie doit
s'engager le marché européen de
l'énergie il ya une question financière
comment financer les investissements
identifiés dans le plan répond ouais de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards dans les
infrastructures électriques gazières et
pétrolières
une taxe sur les énergéticiens beaucoup
débattu dans la presse vous
semble-t-elle utile je crois savoir
votre réponse il y a également une
questions programmatiques une question
d' objectif comment selon vous atteint
les objectifs objectif fixé par le
paquet justement 55 que la commission
propose encore de relever dans le
contexte de guerre je vous laisse donc
la parole pour répondre à ces questions
qui mes collègues nous interrogerons et
je vous proposerai évidemment en premier
lieu d'entendre daniel grémillet sur ces
questions à la suite de vos
interventions je vous propose de
commencer par angie puis par total puis
par des f mais vous vous êtes déjà à 6 9
septembre voilà madame mcgregor merci
beaucoup bonjour bonjour madame la
présidente bonjour mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs donc je vais dans mes
propos liminaire je crois apporter
quelques éléments de réponse à vos
nombreuses et légitimes questions en
particulier bien sûr du point de vue un
petit peu d nj peut-être un point un peu
général sur le système énergétique
européen et donc français puisqu'il faut
savoir que ces systèmes énergétiques
sont quand même très très connectée qui
a été en fait la source est l'origine de
notre tribune puisse effectivement le
système énergétique que nous connaissons
est clairement aujourd'hui mis sous
tension avec des difficultés sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz bien sûr
comme conséquence de la guerre en
ukraine mais d'autres éléments dont
peut-être vous n'avez pas forcément
connaissance par exemple des difficultés
techniques aux états unis avec un
terminal de liquéfaction qui étend pas
les dons qu'il réduit les capacités des
états unis déportés de d'exporter part
dans le gaz naturel liquéfié
la norvège qui est typiquement un très
bon fournisseur aussi a connu des
problèmes et on connaît encore aussi
récemment qu hier donc l'idée de dire
que les livraisons de gaz bien sûr sont
affectés par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
connaître dans le passé sur le parc
électrique et bien sûr mon collègue
d'edf on parlera plus on voit en
particulier la conséquence de la
sécheresse mais aussi des problèmes de
disponibilité du parc nucléaire est en
général important de noter que cet été
la france importe de l'électricité
ce qu'elle ne faisait pas l'été dernier
donc on est vraiment dans une situation
qui est différent du passé
avec une part de ces cgt dont de la
production d'électricité à partir de gaz
aussi qui est relativement important
donc si on regarde la part d'électricité
produite à partir du gaz et les imports
on est à peu près à 15% avec bien sûr en
conséquence à la flambée des prix de
l'énergie que vous connaissez et c'est
un peu ce qui a motivé ces tribunes
puisque en tant que énergéticiens tous
les trois nous avons vraiment une vue
assez un angle assez particulier sur ce
système énergétique et nous avons jugé
qu'il était important que nous avions
une responsabilité qu'il était important
que nous puissions sensibiliser les
français sur cette situation énergétique
française donc et aussi européenne qui
est donc bien sûr avant tout un sujet
d'offres et donc nous nous sommes dit
qu'il fallait ouvrir le dialogue ouvert
le dialogue sur des mesures que nous
pouvions prendre collectivement et alors
la plus portée sur les sujets de demande
pour pouvoir
avoir des solutions à ces sujets
d'offres sur lesquels bien sûr nous
sommes collectivement extrêmement
extrêmement actif il s'agit bien donc
d'économiser l'énergie donc économiser
bien sûr électricité dès maintenant
parce que nous avons ce sujet
d'importation et ce sujet de
consommation de l'électricité à partir
du gaz qui fait que tout électricité
qu'on peut éviter de consommer dès cet
été veut dire que nous aurons plus de
gaz plus de gaz maintenant et évidemment
pour pour l'hiver alors quelques points
d'action sur les sujets de d'offres nous
mettons chéché nj bien sûr et je sais
que patrick pouyanné et mon collègue
marc béziat nous on va en parler
également nous mettons bien sûr en
action des leviers pour agir sur l'offre
avec des possibilités d'accélération
bien sûr donc depuis le premier jour et
après la guerre en ukraine l'idée étant
bien sûr de sécuriser nos
approvisionnements de court terme le
plus possible avec en particulier des
leviers de diversification des sources
d'approvisionnement en utilisant tous
les contrats long terme en signant des
nouveaux contrats avec d'autres
fournisseurs tels que la norvège
l'algérie les états unis une grande
focalisation sur le remplissage des
stockages de gaz qui stockage qui se
passe bien sûr remplissage se passe bien
aujourd'hui en france on est à peu près
à 70 % de remplissage ce qui est plutôt
plus élevé que d'habitude à cette époque
de l'année donc ça c'est plutôt très
positif et puis même une installation
unité flottante de stockage et ça c'est
bien sûr patrick vous en parlera un peu
plus en détail mais bien sur angie nous
nous assurerons que les connexions au
réseau du gaz sont faites en temps et en
heure après il ya bien sûr des actions
de moyen terme et là on est vraiment
dans une logique d'accélération de la
transition énergétique parce que madame
la présidente vous m'avez posé la
question moi j'ai une conviction
extrêmement forte qu'au contraire cette
transition énergétique qui était une
réponse à l'urgence climatique devient
également une réponse aux problèmes de
souveraineté énergétique puisque la
transition énergétique si on l'a même
bien on aura beaucoup plus d'énergie
renouvelable d'énergie produite
localement que ce soit dans l'éolien et
le solaire mais aurait également et sur
le biométhane donc bien sûr pour nous
une opportunité d'accélérer la
transition énergétique avec bien sûr des
difficultés bien sûr des défis bien sûr
à court terme potentiellement vous
l'avez dit des petits pas de côté voire
des petits pas de recul mais l'idée
quand même directionnelle mans c'est
bien accélérer sa transition énergétique
avec la nécessité d'avoir un et de
développer pour la france pour l'europe
un mix équilibré où toutes les
technologies ont leur place je pense
qu'il faut reconnaître que la robustesse
d'un système énergétique doit passer par
la coexistence de plusieurs technologies
chaque technologie ayant en elle même
une ou des vulnérabilités et que la
vraie résilience viendra pas mix
énergétique équilibré donc éolien donc
solaire donc nucléaire donc hydro est
donc bien sûr le gaz dont le biométhane
et le gaz qui sera de plus en plus dé
carbonée
donc pour cette transition c'est
extrêmement important et c'est pour ça
que je crois que nous avons accepté de
très bon coeur devenir à ce débat il
faut apporter le plus possible de la
rationalité et j'espère que ce besoin
d'une souveraineté énergétique permettra
d'apaiser les débats on a vu par exemple
des beaucoup d'émotion autour de
l'éolien je sais pas si le sujet viendra
mais je pense que si on pouvait pas s'y
fier les discussions autour de ces
sujets car après tout l'éolien quand il
est bien fait quand il est fait de
manière responsable c'est de l'énergie
produite en france et en europe donc
nous avons bien sûr ainsi angie des
objectifs importants en termes de
développement d'énergies renouvelables
que ce soit sur l'électrique du
biométhane et on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en parler et bien sûr nous
saluerons la loi d'accélération de la
transition qui va venir en débat au
parlement qui pourra permettre je
l'espère d'accélérer ces énergies
renouvelables encore une fois que ce
soit axé électrique ou renouvelables
enfin troisième point et là j'arrive sur
le sujet plutôt de la demande que j'ai
parlé de l'offre maintenant je passe à
la demande il s'agit bien sûr de
travailler sur la consommation et sur
les clients et avec cette idée de
sobriété énergétique une idée où chaque
petit geste compte alors bien sûr en
tant que industriel nous nous devons
d'être exemplaire donc nous avons pour
nous mêmes des opérations d'efficacité
énergétique importante sur notre parc
immobilier
aujourd'hui bien sûr nous pilotons la
clim avec un degré en plus donc
aujourd'hui la clim dans nos bureaux et
je veux je peux vous dire hier on avait
assez chaud hier à la tour t1 chez angie
puisque la cli ne se déclenche qu'à
partir de 26 degrés chaque petit geste
compte et je pense que c'est vraiment le
message qu'on a voulu passer dans la
tribune c'est que chaque petit geste
compte et donc une sensibilisation bien
sûr de nous de nos couleurs a par
ailleurs en particulier à la sobriété
énergétique pour nos clients nous avons
bien sûr c'est évoluer nos offres pour
les clients particuliers je pense que
mes collègues vont avoir le même type
d'initiative donc je vais aller assez
rapidement mais des offres de pilotage
que ce soit en gaz où on elec le
pilotage est vraiment extrêmement
important permettant à nos clients de
vraiment comprendre comment piloter au
plus fin leur consommation et donc
typiquement réduire et on voit
typiquement quelqu'un qui pilotent sa
consommation peut réduire jusqu'à 15%
d'énergie en le faisant de manière assez
fine on est en train vraiment dû
déployer ses solutions
ainsi que des solutions quand c'est
possible d'optimisation de consommation
électrique sur nos clients
professionnels bien sûr un
accompagnement avec trois types de
solution est bien sûr les réseaux locaux
d'énergie la production d'énergie sur
site la performance la gestion d'énergie
où nous essayons de les aider à
décarbonés le plus possible leur
consommation mais aussi de leur apporter
des solutions d'efficacité énergétique
la tribune a parlé de geste simple nous
avons pas mal d'idées
je pense que en particulier des sujets
autour de la production et la
consommation d'eau chaude peuvent être
des idées qui sont très importantes je
sais pas si vous savez mais la
consommation de gaz pour la production
d'eau chaude sanitaire dans le
résidentiel c'est à peu près 15% de la
consommation donc dès qu'on peut baisser
un petit peu l'eau chaude on a un impact
en fait sur la consommation de gaz est
donc là on a quelques idées assez
concrètes qu'on pourra partager avec
vous ainsi bien sûr que des campagnes
ainsi bien sûr que des campagnes de
consommation que nous allons accélérer
type console type campagne un degré de
moins chaque degré de moins et la oumma
bien sûr pour l'hiver c'est un degré de
plus enclines mais à un degré de moins
en hiver telle campagne qui seront
absolument importante donc voilà je vais
m'arrêter ici pour mais pour mes propos
liminaires et bien sûr je serai
disponible pour répondre à toutes les
questions que vous aurez et je passe la
parole d'un gars merci merci madame
monsieur puyané bonjour madame la
présidente
bonjour mais total energy pas totale
c'est compliqué mais le mot énergie est
important surtout par les temps qui
courent puisque l'entreprise changer
profondément modifier sa stratégie pour
ajouter au pétrole tout le monde connaît
le gars ce qui est très présent
puisqu'on est le deuxième acteur mondial
dans le gaz naturel liquéfié qui devient
célèbre certains demander pourquoi on se
positionnait les événements souvent de
bonnes raisons et puis on devient un
électricien à base d'énergies
renouvelables et de gaz
donc juste un bon d'abord vous savez
l'énergie ces trois piliers ont ce qu'on
réfléchisse ajax et les consommateurs
les clients ils veulent énergies
disponibles c'est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement ils veulent une
énergie abordable j'irai même pas cher
parce que c'est juste essentiel pour
pouvoir d'achat mais aussi pour le
développement économique et social où
que ce soit dans le monde et ils veulent
une énergie durable c'est le climat le
débat a été pas mal depuis quelques en
quelques années le puits 2015 orienté
sur le climat les événements de la crise
ukrainiennes ont tendance à rebat lancé
à rééquilibrer je dirais ce débat nous
rappelons qu'il y à bien les trois
piliers et que l'art d'une politique
énergétique que doivent mener les états
c'est effectivement les capable de
combiner
les trois impératifs mon expérience
depuis 25 ans dans l'énergie je dois
vous avouer que c'est le plus gros
impératifs des trois c'est le prix 1
partout dans le monde ou que je le joue
observe il ya qu'à voir les réactions
dans nos pays y est développée et riche
réaction dès que le prix de l'énergie
montrent donc an l'énergie baisse on
n'entend pas parler d'ailleurs parce
qu'on a quand même vécu les deux
dernières années avant 2022 des prix
extrêmement bas mais quand elle monte
pendant tout le monde réagit donc la
réponse à ce débat c'est qu'en fait et
va dire tout ça c'est la question lui
est posée la transition énergétique
c'est profondément il faut qu'on soit
capable de mener une politique et de
planifier ce qu'on veut faire si on veut
réussir cette transition il faut la
planifier je trouve que les mots
planification sont apparus dans les
titres des membres du gouvernement ça me
paraît extrêmement souhaitable on ne
peut pas continuer à faire cela
simplement géré de façon émotionnelle en
désordre pourquoi faut-il le planifier
parce que le système énergétique
actuelle alors ce n'est pas le cas de la
france mais c'est le cas même si la
france dépend aussi car même largement
des énergies fossiles le nucléaire c'est
l'électricité mais écrit cité ne fait
que 25 30% notre énergie donc faut se
rappeler qu'il ya tous les autres usages
qui sont au chauffage transports à base
d'énergies fossiles notre système actuel
il est à base d'énergies fossiles et ce
que nous devons faire planifié c'est
construire le nouveau système
énergétique décarbonée c'est c'est une
tâche que j'ai des fois je qualifie de
prométhée n sele trilliards de dollars
il faut passer aujourd'hui l'industrie
mondiale de l'énergie investie en gros
10 ans 2 m illiards de dollars par an il
faut être capable de doubler dans les
prochaines années passées 4 c'est ce que
dit les yeux donc il faut énormément
compte augmenter et construire ces
nouvelles énergies
l'erreur qu'on est en train de faire je
dirais l'erreur c'est qu'on veut en même
temps construire le nouveau système et
détruire celui qui nous fait fonctionner
vivre aujourd'hui c'est à dire ces
énergies fossiles on ne pourra le
détruire ou le diminue et que si on a
déjà construit la nouvelle offre
aujourd'hui l'offre d'énergie décarbonée
c'est en gros 15 % du mx mondial ce
n'est pas 50 % dont il faut qu'on arrive
à combiner les deux aspects pourquoi je
dis ça parce qu'il ya eu tout un débat
autour récemment d'ailleurs dans le cas
de latex 2000 européenne sur le
nucléaire le gaz réalité c'est que c'est
pas le nucléaire contre le gars sait il
nous faut les deux il n'oublie faut
ensemble
le gaz est une énergie de transition et
on est en train de le redécouvrir avec
avec notre affaire russo ukrainienne et
je pense que c'est important de garder
cela en tête
donc alors maintenant le débat est aussi
beaucoup sur l'offre on a l'impression
pour faire la transition énergie bien
sûr je viens de le dire il faut
construire une nouvelle offre décarbonée
mais pourquoi on a besoin de cette
transition la transition pour sortir des
fossiles ne sera possible que si la
demande d'énergie fossile baisse
ou la demande tout court la demande
d'énergie je vais revenir sur les échos
de vie mais également la demande
d'énergie fossile or aujourd'hui nos
voitures elles fonctionnent avec du
pétrole nos camions nono ce bateau nous
avions si on fait ce qu'on fait on mène
la politique qui en tellement est en
train d'être mises en oeuvre depuis
quelques années consistant à dire on
investit moins dans le système possible
et que la demande ne baisse pas
simultanément l'ajustement se fait par
le prix et ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est pas seulement des effets violents
et brutaux de la crise russo ukrainienne
c'est aussi le fait que nous avons
fortement diminué depuis 2015 les
investissements dans les énergies
fossiles au niveau mondial pourquoi
parce que d'abord il ya eu les prix en
trombe et c'est donc à une réaction des
acteurs etc en fait d'ailleurs on y
dépense approuvé 400 milliards par an ce
qui est à peu près le niveau que les
yeux nous dit qu'il faudrait pour être
maître 0 le problème c'est que la
demande elle est continue à monter au
niveau planétaire parce que la
population augmente et donc on a
aujourd'hui une espèce de
de déséquilibre entre une demande qui a
continué à monter une offre est alors
naturellement vous savez dans le métier
des pétroliers les gaziers il ya une
caractéristique
contrairement d'ailleurs allé aux
énergies renouvelables que j'aime de
plus en plus c'est que si nous
n'investissons pas chaque année on perd
4% notre capacité de production parce
que les puits perdre de la pression donc
on n'investit pas chaque année on perd
4% ce qui veut dire d'ailleurs le jour
où on décidera qu'on a insisté assez
d'énergie décarbonnée c'est pas très
compliqué pour mon entreprise à ce
moment là de baisser ma production de
pétrole et gaz il suffira que mon des
sites arrêter d'investir aujourd'hui si
je le fais c'est trop tôt fait trop tôt
parce que je ne suis pas capable selon
la d'assurer la demande mais au moment
où on va voir et c'est pour ça qu'on
organise sa stratégie pour ajouter
l'électricité pour préparer le futur au
mans on va voir la demande de pétrole
commençait à baisser et bien cela
naturellement les bains il suffira qu on
investisse - et on verra 3 ou 4 %
d'économies par an 3 ou 4 fois 20 ans ça
va vite donc voilà donc c'est un point
qu'il faut avoir en tête alors après sur
la demande comme on l'a dit dans cette
tribune moi je suis ravi de m'être
associé à mes deux collègues les trois
électriciens ensemble ce qui prouve que
le sujet est important que chacun
d'entre nous individuellement rue paul
en moins de porter ce que j'observe dans
les sondages après cette tribune c'est
que 65% des français approuvent et on
rigole on lui et enfin ont réagi
positivement pourquoi parce que les
meilleurs au moment on parle de pouvoir
d'achat on en reparle de climat les
meilleures énergies si c'est pour
consomme pas et qu' il faut c'est
l'opportunité ou jamais pour moi parce
qu'on innove quand on est dans une crise
comme on peut l'être c'est ok le casio
jamais justement d'aider collectivement
tous ensemble c'est pas désigné
consommateurs et nos entreprises aussi
doit faire des économies et je vais en
parler d'abord un mouvement collectif
massif comme on les a eus oui d'ailleurs
je veux dire le titre de la tribune
c'est le journal qui a choisi ce n'est
pas du tout celui qu'on avait recommandé
nous c'est et mobilisons nous pour les
économies d'énergie et j'étais même moi
j'avais même mis la chasse au gaspi de
retour voyez comme parce que j'avais été
très marquée quand j'étais jeune ba est
le pari pris toilettes pas les radios
l'argent rappelle les compteurs à
essence il avait deux dj de fallait
passer à un front quelque chose avait
été bien ça nous avait tous
collectivement et ya plein de petits
gestes qu'on avait appris il faut juste
qu'on réapprenne le chauffage à 19
degrés la clim à 26
la machine à laver à 30 degrés et 800
tours milieu de mon dit un
non mais arrêtez arrêtez les bureaux
arrêter les bureaux les immeubles de
bureaux à 22h on coupe automatiquement
les lumières dans ce bureau tout un
théâtre qui vont pas le but c'est pas
d'embêter les gens c'est simplement de
remettre dans notre crâne ce qu'on avait
appris qu on était jeune alors après
bien sûr nous moi entreprises total
énergie il se trouve que oui en ce
moment là des résultats plus élevés et
qu'on a décidé d'ailleurs de consacrer
un milliard l'année prochaine à
économiser l'énergie dans toute
l'entreprise parce que je suis un très
gros consommateur d'énergie moi même
dans les raffineries et donc on a nos
propres programmes d'économies argy donc
c'est une mobilisation qu'il faut faire
et il se trouve qu'en plus ça touche
boire d'achat les l'argent ça touche les
émissions et ça contribue à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement tout ce qu'on pourra
faire or aujourd'hui pour répondre à
votre question oui on s'est mobilisé on
n'a jamais autant nous n'avons pas
d'allergie jamais autant importé de gnl
en europe que durant le dernier hiver
tous les terminaux que nous avons et
nous avons à peu près 25% des capacités
européennes d'importation de gnl sont
pleines on était plein et nous
continuerons à le faire pourquoi pas ce
que vus nous sommes deuxième acteur
mondial nous produisons du gnl dans plus
dans onze usines différentes nous sommes
le premier exportateur de gaz naturel
liquéfié des états unis et notamment on
l'a redirigé vers l'europe bien
évidemment et dans ce cadre là on a
proposé au gouvernement puisque on a
deux unités flottantes de regazification
d'en mettre une wavre qui viendra en 70
2023 si le parlement approuve le projet
de loi parce qu'on a besoin continu des
procédures d'un projet de loi pour
accélérer
non pas pour passer outre le débat
démocratique simplement pour regrouper
les procédures en une pour éviter de
perdre et donc ça c'est très important
qu'on est que ce projet de loi soit
adoptée si je le dis puisque j'en
profite que je suis présent et et
de commissions je sais est par ailleurs
la deuxième unité flottante le
gouvernement allemand sachez le nous a
contactés récemment pour qu'on implante
la deuxième en allemagne en france on a
regardé les autres sites il se trouve
que pour des raisons de réseau le havre
est bien placé genre avec grtgaz et
hadji dunkerque et fos n'apporterait pas
grand-chose contenu après d écoulement
vers l'europe donc on est en train de se
mobiliser
le terminal du havre sachez que total
energy a accepté la demande du
gouvernement de l'opérer de prendre en
charge les désinvestissements et de
fournir le gaz donc on assurera ses
représente quand même 5 milliards de
mètres cubes par an donc c'est un apport
intéressant je dirais qu'il fait 15% de
la consommation pour injecter plus de
gaz dans le système européen je pense
qu'il faut se mettre dans l'idée que
d'une façon ou d'une autre le gaz russe
va s'arrêter et que et que d'ailleurs de
temps en temps presque le fait qu'on
aurait décidé de l'arrêter de nous-mêmes
européen il y traite donner une arme au
président russe contre nous pour nous je
dirais savez nous le supplice à petit
feu là en ce moment et donc il faut se
mettre pour cette idée là on s'y est mis
aujourd'hui les stocks remonte donc tout
ça va bien alors un mot quand même des
énergies renouvelables parce que dans ce
paysage là ils ont un vrai rôle elles
sont locales elles sont locales
elles dépendent de nous donc les
énergies renouvelables c'est un moyen
d'assurer notre indépendance énergie
parle pas du nucléaire parce que je vais
laisser mon collègue d'edf et je
soutiens tout à fait le programme
français décidée par le gouvernement sur
le nucléaire mais il faut qu' il faut
c'est local donc c'est il faut se
mobiliser sur le biogaz bien évidemment
parce que ça j'ai dit gaz énergie
transition il pourra y avoir une suite
dé carbonée il faut se mobiliser sur les
énergies
terrestre alors je sais que le solaire a
plus de publicité que l'éolien certains
d'entre vous m'écrivent direct et
régulièrement des courriers donc je fais
attention mais l'éolien offshore est un
vrai potentiel il faut savoir en tête
quand même que les trois énergéticiens
français ont dépensé au début de l'année
2000 21 puis de 2 milliards de dollars
pour acheter des concessions aux états
unis c'est angie edf nos trois
concessions offshore
j'aurais préféré quelque part pouvoir
dépenser cet argent
puisqu'en fait c'est les ressources
rares acheter du domaine maritime c'est
comme des fréquences terrestre et
d'ailleurs je trouve que plutôt que voir
des procédures compliquées l'attribution
aux etats unis c'est assez simple ce
sont des enchères les trois d'entre 3
chacun d'entre nous il y avait sept
concessions offertes on en a acheté
chacun une dépensé deux milliards de
dollars et est finalement on va réaliser
derrière les projets et qui sont des
projets pour ce qui me contrait de près
de 2 de 3 gigawatts donc c'est des
énormes concessions on a également fait
la même chose au royaume uni dont moi
j'aspire maintenant à ce qu'en france on
lance ses concessions maritimes et qu on
les lance de façon la plus transparente
et la plus rapide possible après aux
industriels de prendre les risques comme
on l'a fait au royaume uni ou aux états
unis voilà ce que je reprendrai bon je
ne vais pas parler des ordinateurs j'ai
un point de vue là dessus je pense qu'il
faut quelque part probablement mieux
s'organiser moi c'est le mot planifié je
pense qu'il est important pour votre loi
à venir il faut planifier l'espace les
renouvelables leur vrai sujet ce qui est
rare c'est les terres
la limite c'est les territoires moi
c'est aujourd'hui j'ai des gens partout
qui cherchent à avoir accédé territoire
pour être honnête je pense que on
s'épuise avec des procédures je me
demande dans quelle mesure il faut pas
qu'on pense l'éolien terrestre comme on
l'a fait pour des grandes zones
industrielles c'est d'avoir des vrais
des grands parcs éoliens terrestres dans
des zones où il n'y a pas de pas trop
d'habitants mais il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui les éparpiller imiter le
paysage avec des éoliennes ça commence à
poser problème et j'avais c'est très
inefficace pour nous parce que pour
mettre 10 éoliennes on y passe trois ou
quatre ans ce qui à la fin fait quelques
mégawatts et ne règle pas du tout le
problème de la transition donc il faut
qu'on repense ce sujet de façon ap mais
il faut planifier l'espace avec les
régions avec les territoires parce que
les acteurs privés que nous sommes ne
pouvons pas à nous tous seuls on peut
pas se substituer à des puissances
publiques la planification et une
responsabilité de l'état et des
collectivités voilà ce que je dirais
pour l'introduction sur ces sujets là
merci beaucoup monsieur pouilles est née
je vous laisse la parole ce benayoun sur
le point de vue d'edf
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je tiens tout
d'abord à excuser jean bernard lévy qui
signataires de cette tribune on ou non
parler qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être
présents ce jour et je voudrais vous
remercier aussi d'avoir invité le groupe
edf à s'exprimer sur des sujets
énergétiques particulièrement brûlant en
ce moment l'actualité nous rappelle
l'ampleur du défi que représente le
basculement de nos sociétés vers un
monde notre en carbone la guerre en
ukraine a mis en évidence la dépendance
de l'europe à la con à la aux
importations de gaz russe même si sur ce
plan la france est plutôt mieux placé
que la moyenne européenne va nettement
mieux placé et elle nous incite à
réduire notre consommation de gaz
évidemment à ce titre est par ailleurs
la production nucléaire fait face à des
arrêts de tranche prolonger cette année
pour un sujet dont vous avez entendu
parler bien sûr la corrosion sous
contraintes etc qui se traduit par des
perspectives de production plus basse
que les valeurs nominales que les
valeurs moyennes historiques pour 2022
et 2023 donc ce champ de contraintes
évidemment nous amène à revoir la
gestion de nos approvisionnements et à
faire tout ce qui est possible pour
sécuriser le système électrique et un
assuré un assurer l'équilibré d'autant
que dans le système électrique vous le
savez il n'y a pas de capacité de
stockage donc il ya un enjeu d'énergie
qu'il faut livrer à nos clients pour
l'hiver mais aussi de puissance qu'il
faut assurer à la pointe cette dualité
avant la question encore un peu plus un
peu plus difficile donc à ce sujet une
task force a été mise en place par le
gouvernement pour voir ce qui se passe
si on s'approche d'une pénurie parce
qu'on l'a on la voit venir quand même en
général c'est lié à des conditions soit
de difficultés d'exploitation de
difficultés d'un porc ou de ou de
conditions climatiques qui augmente la
puissance appelée et donc à proximité de
la crise si des décisions doivent être
prises via le gouvernement le fera et
nous travaillons bien sûr dans le cas de
cette task force pour préparer
effectivement une éventuelle une
éventuelle crise donc sur un plan plus
structurel maintenant et pour parler
vraiment de demander de ce2 de sobriété
je tiens à rappeler et à illustrer
l'engagement de longue date du groupe
edf pour les usages performant de
l'électricité c'est un leitmotiv chez
nous un de nos grands dirigeants il y a
une vingtaine d'années disait il faut
développer tous les usages de
l'électricité avec le moins
d'électricité par usage et ça paraît
anecdotique mais on n'a jamais cherché à
développer les volumes consommés chez
nos clients on a toujours cherché à
développer la présence de l'électricité
mais à développer des usages performant
et de la même passion d'un
positionnement de conseils de nos
clients qui est ailleurs une obligation
titre du tarif réglementé vente c'est
que lorsque des clients nous appellent
nous leur posons de nombreuses questions
sur l'installation pour qu'ils aient le
contrat le plus adapté à leurs besoins
donc concrètement ne pas leur donner une
souscription de 12 kg à 6,6 ce
qu'avaient à suffisent donc depuis dix
ans nous avons promu une application qui
s'appelle edf et moi qui permet de
donner tous nos clients particuliers
alors il ya des dispositifs aussi pour
les entreprises mais qui permet de
donner à tous les particuliers des
informations précises sur leur
consommation sur le coût de celle ci sur
l'offre sur leur courbe de charge de
plus que l'ong qui a été développé c'est
un très grand avantage et ça permet de
proposer à nos clients des éco gestes
des gestes permettant de modérer leur
consommation ou de leur suggérer aussi
des pros pts et comme on dirait des
remplacement d'équipements parce que sur
la base d'une cours de charge on sait
dire si la difficulté c'est une
consommation électrique de froid de
d'électricité de d'éclairage ou d'autres
ou d'autres usages de l'électricité donc
ça c'est un point très important et nous
avons fait des analyses sur les faits
que pouvait avoir la consommer de la
consultation régulière de ceux de cette
information les clients qui sont les
plus utilisateurs de ce dispositif
arrive à des réductions de consommation
jusqu'à 12% et en moyenne on est à 5%
par an donc c'est tout à fait important
les petits gestes la mobilisation de
tous ce n'est pas d'ordre 2 c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait
significatif alors maintenant
effectivement même si nous faisons des
campagnes pour promouvoir ses disposé
ces dispositifs il n'y a que six
millions de français parmi les 22
millions qui sont clients d'edf qui
utilisent ces applications malgré tous
les efforts que nous faisons et nous
nous aimerions doubler ce chiffre et
nous pensons que l'éclat campagne que va
faire le gouvernement à la rentrée pour
développer la souveraineté nous aidera à
nous avec nos propres campagnes à
diffuser ses moyens qui sont des moyens
d'informer d'alerté d'inciter les
clients à consommer moins dans le
domaine des entreprises nous avons aussi
des offres tout à fait significatives
pour aider nos clients dans l'industrie
ou dans les collectivités locales à
consommer moins la société dalkia qui
est un des leaders des services
énergétiques en france qui comporte
vingt mille personnes diffuse et des
contrats de performance énergétique
depuis sa création dans lesquelles elles
s'engagent en fait parce qu'elle a la
main sur les équipements du client elle
s'engage à une réduction de la facture
du client et de sa consommation et quand
j elle s'engage dire que s'il à la
consommation n'a pas baissé comme prévu
dans le contrat c'est dalkia qui paie la
différence donc là on prend un risque
financier et dans certains cas le le
volume de réduction sur des périodes
contractuels qui vont de 5 ans à 10 ans
peut être de -40% voyons prend
l'installation d'un client et on lui
promet jusqu'à -40 % de réduction même
si plus souvent nés sur - 15 - dont vous
voyez il ya beaucoup d'offres vers tous
les clients qui permettent de modérer la
consommation d'énergie d'ailleurs je
vous ai je vous ai distribué deux plans
joyent deux choses très intéressantes
c'est que depuis les années je crois
77-78 la consommation d'électricité ne
monte plus en france non pardon depuis
2000 excusez moi elle ne monte plus en
france on est à 470 térawatts heure de
consommation d'électricité finale malgré
la croissance économique malgré le
développement de la démographie et
malgré le développement des usages et
donc ça c'est bien le signe il y à un
effort particulier un de productivité
que nous accompagnons et que nous
appuyons avec avec nos offres notre
élément assez intéressant c'est la
consommation moyenne par ménage vous
voyez on est passé depuis 2010 de 5,6
mégawattheure ou 5600 kilowattheure les
factures des clients sont plutôt rédigé
en kilowattheures on est passé de 5000 6
à 4007 oui c'est quand même moins 15%
c'est tout à fait significatif alors que
dans le même temps le nombre d' usage
par foyer ne cesse d'augmenter oui c'est
un point quand même très important et
notre rôle d'énergéticien aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement d'accélérer ses
efforts de les réaliser chez nous comme
l'ont très bien expliqué madame mcgregor
éméché puyané nous si nous faisons des
efforts très importants même que nous
faisons aussi des efforts pour
décarbonés nos usages nos propres usages
énergétiques par exemple nous nous
sommes engagés pour que la totalité de
nos flottes de véhicules sur des flottes
électrique on est déjà 18% voyez c'est
un an fait partie des quelques
entreprises dans le monde qui se sont
engagés à électrifier totalement
totalement la flotte donc voyais
effectivement c'est
c'est un effort de longue haleine c'est
un effort cumulatif c'est vrai que cette
année nous amène à faire une des
campagnes peut être encore plus
approfondie pour pousser la sobriété
pour pousser un juste usage de
j mais ce sont des efforts cumulatif
qu'ils ont qui vont payer dans la durée
je rajouterais un petit point c'est la
question de l'effacement que l'on peut
considérer comme de la sobriété mais
c'est peut-être je dirais un abus de
langage en fait les fascinants c'est
très important dans le secteur
électrique ça consiste en fait à incité
un client à ne pas consommer une journée
qui risque d'être particulièrement tendu
mais a reporté sa consommation ensuite
ça c'est quelque chose qui représente à
la pointe 4 à 5 gigawatts dont quand les
puissances appelées à la pointe sont de
90 on a eu une fois
maximum à 100 à 100 gigawatts de deux
caps de puissance appelée donc ses
capacités d'effacement sont elles qui
véritablement doivent aussi être
encouragés pour gérer effectivement un
possible manque de puissance cet hiver
lié aux difficultés que j'ai indiqué en
introduction
donc pour les clients ce sont des tarifs
soit des tarifs postaux saisonnier donc
heures pleines heures creuses et ses 10
millions de nos clients sur 22 qui sont
équipés de ces tarifs dont qui incitent
à consommer la nuit plutôt qu'à leur
plein et c'est aussi des offres que nous
allons relancer le gouvernement nous
demande de le faire notamment l'option
tempo qui est une offre dans laquelle
effectivement le client un certain
nombre de jours par an s'il consomme
vacances va payer un prix supérieur et
donc on va ainsi l'inciter à déplacer sa
consommation du jour j au jour j + 1
donc c'est ce sont des efforts très
importants et nous sommes effectivement
un opérateur majeur dans ce domaine de
de l'effacement voici ce que je voulais
partager avec vous aujourd'hui et vous
dire que nous sommes très fiers
d'accompagner ces transformations dans
le domaine de la tous les domaines de la
consommation d'électricité et de gaz
nous ne sommes pas un acteur du pétrole
mais nous sommes un acteur donc delà de
la promotion et de la vente de
l'électricité et et du gaz pour
décarbonés pour décarbonés l'économie et
cela représente chez nous 30000 salariés
donc c'est une activité très importante
à la présence d'edf à laval et qui
effectivement se traduit qui permet de
porter toutes ses offres destinées à à
modérer la consommation voilà donc je
vous remercie pour votre attention et je
serai maintenant heureux de répondre à
vos questions
très bien merci beaucoup pour ces trois
intervention liminaire il ya beaucoup de
questions je vais commencer par notre
président du groupe d'études énergie
daniel grémillet et merci madame
présente voilà la directrice générale
monsieur le président le général
monsieur le directeur exécutif chers
collègues
effectivement première remarque
s'agissant du volet souveraineté
énergétique du projet doit pouvoir
d'achat il comporte plusieurs
dispositions pour contraindre des
remplissages des stocks gérés des
coupures de gaz réguler les
installations où les méthaniers ou
encore quand ce délai la reine les
contraintes et les indemnités vous
semble-t-elle proportionnée et que
pensez-vous de la reine ne faut-il pas
leur mettre un plat concernant le
boucler le bouclier tarifaire le
considérez-vous satisfaisant on sait que
les jeunes tarifaire pénalise l'ensemble
des fournisseurs est le relèvement du
plafond de la reine le groupe def à
combien évaluez-vous cet impact du point
de vue des consommateurs seuls 22 % de
notre consommation nationale est
couverte par l'état des frais glement
thé et de l'électricité et seulement 7 %
pour ceux du gaz
quid des clients non éligibles comme
certaines entreprises ou collectivités
et comment anticiper l'avenir car le
bouclier tarifaire arrive à expiration
en 2023 avec un rattrapage à pleuvoir
sur les consommateurs et enfin ne
doit-on pas accorder une attention
spécifique aux ménages en situation de
précarité énergétique plus de 3.5
millions se trouvent dans cette
situation avant la crise gazière
actuelle faut-il renforcer les actions
leur direction notamment par ma prime à
neuf ou les ses deux dauphins des
certificats d'économie d'énergie merci
je fais peut-être laissé vous laisser
répondre
à ses premières questions avant de
prendre des séries d'autres questions
qui veut réagir il ya quelques questions
sur l'électricité répondre à monsieur
guy minier bon je vais pas faire un long
couplet sur la reine vous savez à quel
point l'entreprise est hostile à ce
dispositif qui nous a coûté extrêmement
cher mais par ailleurs il n'a pas
d'effet immédiat sur le sujet qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui puisque c'est un
moyen simplement de mettre à disposition
de deux concurrents de l'électricité
nucléaire qui est déjà là donc ça n'a
pas d'effet si je puis dire sur l'
équilibre offre offre demande sur le
bouclier tarifaire ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que effectivement il se traduit il
s'est traduit par un net divergence des
prix de l'électricité payée en france
par rapport au reste de l'europe il y
avait un écart typiquement de 25% on est
maintenant dans un écart de 1 à 2 là
aussi d'ailleurs je peux vous donner
quelques quelques éléments mais à
nouveau placé il faut rappeler un point
tout à fait central ce n'est pas edf qui
fixe les tarifs de l'électricité c'est
le gouvernement qui les fixent sur la
base d'une proposition de la cre eux sur
la la précarité énergétique ce que l'on
peut dire c'est que les les dispositifs
pour aider les clients en situation de
précarité sont nombreux il s'agit
notamment du chèque énergie mais aussi
de toutes toutes les incitations à faire
des travaux chez eux notamment les c29
ce avec le dispositif décès 2e comporte
deux volets ses deux essais 2 pour les
clients très clair et grands précaires
ça a permis effectivement avec ma prime
rénove de de faire un effort de je
dirais de financer parce que c'est pas
nous qui le faisons mais nous nous le
finançons travers des c2 eu un effort de
rénovation des parce qu'on appelle les
passoires énergétiques le terme n'est
pas beau mais je crois que tout le monde
comprend bien l'idée et cet effort il
peut certainement il peut certainement
être accrue mais je pense qu'entre les
efforts qui sont faits et le prix payé
il n'y a pas tellement de pays en europe
ont fait mieux pour la précarité
énergétique que pour que pour la france
puisque effectivement dans la majorité
maintenant des pays européens le prix de
l'électricité il est deux fois le prix
payé l'a pas payé en france et les prix
du gaz sont souvent équivalent ont un
peu supérieur tse donc on est plutôt un
pays à bien protéger les clients en
situation de précarité
juste pour compléter selon claire sur la
reine céphalées concurrents qui a
professé les clients des concurrents
puisque comme on s'y était engagé bien
évidemment lorsqu'on reçoit une tranche
de à 50 euros ou 48 euros du mégawatt on
la transfère dans les caries filiale atr
vais donc ce n'est jamais qu'un en fait
la vérité dans cette affaire c'est qu'en
passant de 100 à 120 térawattheures le
gouvernement a fait absorber via cette
mise à disposition de 21 à water une
partie du bouclier tarifaire de façon à
ce que ça soit pas de l'argent
budgétaires alors effectivement vu
l'entreprise edf ça pèse sur
l'entreprise edf mais il faut clair nous
ne prenons aujourd'hui notre entreprise
puisque j'ai 3 4 millions de clients en
france le bouclier tarifaire pèse sur
nous et dans les résultats français
total énergie puisque c'est un sujet à
la mode autant les parties raffinage de
la gagner l'argent autant la partie
distribution de gaz elle est restée père
lourdes demandes d'argent je dois donc
ce bouquet tarifaire moi je pense que
comme il les dit en ce moment et la
réaction immédiate il faut aussi quelque
part à mon avis réservé ce genre de
mesures pour les populations les plus
fragiles je pense qu'à un moment
certaines populations que la sorte à
pouvoir la chape peut doit connaître la
réalité de ce prix de l'énergie parce
que la transition énergétique faut pas
se leurrer investir des trilliards de
dollars ça va coûter de l'argent et donc
il ya quelque chose qui est faux de
faire croire à nos concitoyens qu'on va
réussir à transformer le système
énergétique qui l'énergie qui coûtera le
même prix voire moins cher ça c'est pas
vrai on va devoir faire cohabiter
pendant plusieurs années les deux
systèmes donc je pense que bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui on a un problème
d'amortir les sur choque et ça il faut
quand même prendre trouver les mesures
le moyen de le faire mais en même temps
il faut qu on habitue petit à petit au
fait que cette énergie et j'ai dit que
je suis conscient que tout le monde veut
qu'elle soit bon marché mais quelque
part elle ne coûtera plus cher pendant
cette phase de transition donc on sait
au gouvernement définir les mesures mais
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui bouquet
tarifaire compte tenu que la crise russo
ukrainienne se poursuit il ya peu de
chances de voir les prix du gaz en
europe baisser pour être honnête il - ou
qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui mais enfin
ils n'ont pas baissé donc ça veut dire
que cette somme qui avait été je vous
rappelle le système c'était l'idée que
c'est passager on fait un bouclier un
premier hiver et puis que l'année
suivante on pourra se retrouverai se
récupérer on n'est pas parti dans ce
scénario là donc moi je pense qu'il
serait dangereux dangereux d'accumuler
des sommes très importantes qui
devraient due à des fournisseurs donc
voilà ce que je pouvais lire les
contraintes légales de la loi pour ce
que j'ai pu voir ça m'a paru en première
approximation j'ai pas de commentaire
mais ça m'a j'ai pas vu des notes de mes
équipes de deux points deux points
chauds à ce niveau là voilà ce que je
pouvais répondre à vos trois points
et peut-être en complément sur la reine
a effectivement c'est un outil que nous
pensons important pour les fournisseurs
alternatifs qui peuvent utiliser ces
volumes pour proposer des offres
intéressantes et nous on est plutôt au
contraire de se dire un mécanisme comme
ça pour 2023 plus on peut les anticiper
et mieux c'est parce que c'est
maintenant qu'on est en train de
construire des offres nos clients année
prochaine leur donner la visibilité et
un accès à une énergie à prix plus
modérées nous paraît plutôt au contraire
présenterai très importants et un
bouclier tarifé à bien sûr plus ciblées
pour les clients les plus précaires et
paraît également une très bonne idée je
rajouterai qu il ya également des
mécanismes qu'on peut utiliser je
voudrais souligner un mécanisme qui
appelle le fonds solidarité logement moi
qui me paraît très intéressant parce
qu'il a des applications extrêmement
locales et donc permet aux conseils
départementaux de d'aider leurs clients
par le biais de ses dotations donc nous
avons augmenté bien sûr un compte tenu
des circonstances
je pense que pouvoir aider de manière
très ciblée localement en utilisant la
présence locale les clients les plus
précaires me paraît un outil très
vertueux que nous avons que nous avons
utilisé voilà et sur la loi je pense que
c'est vraiment important les le
remplissage des stocks après le
mécanisme de garantie de l'état restent
encore à définir
mes chers collègues vous êtes très
nombreux à demander la parole je vous
propose qu'on prenne les questions par
quatre si vous le permettez et je vous
demande d'être attentifs au fait qu' on
refasse pas les mêmes questions
plusieurs fois voilà merci beaucoup la
parole est à françoise férat ensuite à
franck montaugé
merci madame la présidente merci madame
messieurs pour votre présence ce matin
je pense que ma question s'adresse
particulièrement monsieur pouyanne est
le prolongement de la guerre en ukraine
et les conséquences de ce conflit font
craindre aux professionnels de l'énergie
et à leurs clients de graves difficultés
d'approvisionnement j'aime explique j'ai
été interpellé par un professionnel de
mon département la marne livreur de
fioul de gros volumes de très gros
volumes il constate en effet et depuis
plusieurs mois une diminution de
réapprovisionnement du clientèle
confrontés à des prix dissuasif espérant
je pense une mesure analogue à celle
appliquée à d'autres énergies espérant
évidemment une baisse de tarifs
concernant l' usage du fioul domestique
particulièrement utilisez vous le savez
en zone rurale les trois millions de
résidences principales ont la capacité
de stocker près de 90 % de la
consommation annuelle
anticipée réapprovisionnement dès la
rentrée des chaudières à fuel
permettrait peut-être de limiter la
hausse des coûts de ce carburant
al'inverse d'une collecte concentrait
sur les périodes de chauffe d'une part
et constituerait je pense une véritable
stratégie de stockage d'autre part j'ai
saisi le ministre de l'économie et des
finances
sous forme d'une question écrite sur ce
sujet il n'a pas encore eu le temps de
me répondre
le risque de rupture d'approvisionnement
fioul domestique afin de connaître pour
le coup la stratégie du gouvernement et
garantir la fourniture des ménages qui
se chauffent avec ce carburant je
souhaite savoir si de votre côté
des stratégies sont réfléchies prête à
lui être être mises en oeuvre pour
autistes droite ici p le stockage éviter
la rupture d'approvisionnement pour les
ménages merci merci françoise franck
montaugé ensuite fabien gay merci madame
la présidente merci à vous trois pour
votre présentation
je me fais le porte parole de serge
mérillou qui a pas pu être parmi nous
et qui vous pouvez qu'être qu'étant
vision et qui demande à edf à monsieur b
benayoun si edf possède des prévisions
divulgue abl communicables pour l'hiver
prochain en matière de production compte
tenu des difficultés que rencontre le
parc
nucléaire voilà ce qu'on peut être
encore à un niveau de production
historiquement bas de l'ordre de 300
terrato térawattheures vous ne le dirais
pour ce qui me concerne vous avez parlé
monsieur benayoun d'effacement de
délestage
il existe à ma connaissance à moins que
c était supprimé
dans la tarification
d'edf en tout cas de l'électricité un
tarif qui s'appelle ou qui s'appelait
effacement jour de pointe est-ce que ce
tarif fait partie
de la boîte à outil qui permettrait
justement de répondre aux questions de
d'effacement voilà et dernière dernière
question adressée à vous trois
beaucoup d'économistes spécialistes
disent que le jeu ne croit aussi que le
prix du carbone aujourd'hui sur le
marché et est beaucoup trop bas qu'il
faudrait qu'ils soient plus élevés et
que d'un nouveau modèle de décision
d'entreprise
concernant notamment les investissements
que vous engagez que vous décidez les
taux d'actualisation que vous utilisez
donc qui permettent d' arbitrer entre le
présent et le lointain dans le temps
devrait être harmonisés pour justement
faciliter la transition énergétique
donc je voudrais savoir si sûr c'est sur
ces deux points vous avez des critiques
des réflexions les propositions
d'affaires merci merci
merci madame la présidente bonjour à
tous les trois
j'ai des points d'accord et puis
beaucoup de points de désaccord
ça vous surprendra pas
ça serait l'un vers ce serait illogique
en sciences j'ai un point d'accord avec
madame mcgregor c'est que toute
fabrication d'énergie a un impact sur la
nature toute activité humaine un impact
sur la nature et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on pourra limiter les risques il faut
un mix énergétique je suis entièrement
d'accord avec lui le reste je suis en
désaccord sur un certain nombre de
choses mais philosophiquement et
politiquement je pense que les crises
que nous allons aborder et la question
énergétique
nous est posée en grand on doit sortir
l'énergie du marché et la considérer
quand même bien con mais ça c'est un
débat politique entre nous par exemple
si on ne sort pas edf des griffes du
marché où la reine
edf va continuer à être plombée par
exemple et ça c'est un désarroi mais ce
puyané je comprends que cela arrange la
reine mais le gouvernement a demandé à
edf d'aller acheter des terrains water à
350 voire 350
365 euros sur le marché libre pour
ensuite les randonnées et les revendre à
ses principaux concurrents au prix de 42
euros c'est une aberration totale c'est
même pas le capitalisme libre et non
faussée c'est le capitalisme libre et
surtout fossé pardonnez moi et donc si
on ne sort pas de ça nous allons être
mis en très grande difficulté bon ça
c'est un désaccord profond et puis un
deuxième et même question sera courte on
va avoir un débat sur le pouvoir d'achat
et une proposition projet de loi porté
par le gouvernement notamment sur la
question énergétique faut pas oublier
quand même que pour 12 millions de
français la question n'est pas de savoir
s'ils mettent leur chauffage à 19 20 ou
21 c'est que 12 millions de personnes
ils peuvent pas mettre le chauffage
c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui est donc
moi je suis pour qu il y ait de
l'information mais je suis pas pour
qu'on culpabilise un certain nombre
d'usagers pareil sur la question de la
voiture 18 millions de personnes sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture et donc
je suis pas pour qu'on culpabilise les
gens qui utilisent leur voiture
individuelle parce qu'ils sont privés
transport collectif c'est exactement la
même question mais pour éclairer le
débat moi je pense que nous avons besoin
de deux données
la première c'est que depuis six mois
d'inflation on a besoin de savoir qu'ils
pas qu'il faut pas de profit mais savoir
les surprofits et les méga profit par
exemple je vais citer un grand auteur
michel edouard leclerc on ne peut pas
dire qu'il est communiste qui a dit
qu'une partie de l'inflation était de
l'anticipation la spoliation on a besoin
de savoir ça pour quoi parce que c'est
pas le même débat ensuite que nous
devons avoir ici et pareil pour l'état
l'état le principal question de rentrée
d'argent c'est la tva et donc quand il
ya l'inflation les caisses se
remplissent et donc il est facile de
venir ensuite dire on va vous donner 10
redonner 18 centimes sauf que si les
entreprises font 30 ou 40 centimes de
mega profits et l'état en grange lui
aussi 30 ou 40 centimes de tva
supplémentaires et donc que ça pèse pour
80 centimes dans le portefeuille des
françaises et des français il est un peu
facile de revenir et de leur dire au
final on va vous rendre que 18 centimes
je pense qu'il nous faut des données
claires et simples combien de plus six
mois de mai gaout sur profits pour les
entreprises et combien pour l'état de
tva supplémentaires et après nous aurons
un débat chers collègues est ce qu'il
faut en rendre totalement séméga profit
est-ce que partiellement et si c'est
partiellement à quelle hauteur parce que
je pense que les 18 centimes rendu
aujourd'hui à la pompe à essence ne
prennent pas en compte l'ensemble des
surprofits réalisés par les entreprises
et par la tva par l'état que on a spolié
en partie aux usagers notamment des
pompes à essence voilà ma question
on attendait pas moins fabien jean
claude tissot feu en
visio
les changes qui nous permet d'aborder
directement les risques
d'approvisionnement énergétique et bien
sûr l'indispensable chemin accra c'est
d'un autre nouvelle peu énergétique
il souhaitait revenir rapidement sur la
crise mine que vous avez récemment
réalisées sur cette thématique et qui a
logiquement suscité de nombreuses
réactions comme on l'avait d'ailleurs
qui vous des quarts et dans cette
tribune la meilleure énergie reste cette
chronique consommons parti et j'aime
pourront pleinement vous rejoindre sur
la vie
politique je tenais à vous faire part
mais comme ça a déjà été dit par des
collègues de ma surprise quand à ces
déclarations et même si vos intentions
sont certainement louable il est un peu
facile de demander ces efforts française
blanc de la cohésion sociale
même participé à cette ultra
libéralisation du marché d'énergie
et à cette spéculation continue dont
nous payons pas partie des conséquences
aujourd'hui ainsi de manière assez
directe je souhaiterais savoir si
l'expérience des derniers mois à la
croisée entre la crise sanitaire et la
traîne a fait évoluer votre regard sur
l'organisation du marché européen
d'énergie première question et vous
parle également d'une action à l'échelle
de l'europe et d'une solidarité
européenne comment ces principes
peuvent-ils s'inscrire dans marché
actuel est ce le rôle des
investissements publics de compenser les
lacunes de ce marché cela profite
finalement au bout de la chaîne à des
acteurs privés ou n'est il pas
nécessaire de revoir en profondeur son
organe a su enfin jouer très rapidement
revenir cela sobriété énergétique dont
vous parlez de cette manière nécessaire
sobriété d'exception et sans être
despotique des dogmatiques je considère
qu'il s'agit d'une condition
indispensable pour permettre notre
ambition énergie notre transition
énergétique est selon vous quel rôle
peuvent jouer les nerfs
vous remercie
voilà des questions dire qu'ils vont
directement au but
c'est pour ma première et puis après je
laisserais celle qui est où je sens que
je peux répondre et des hauts des bas
bon le fioul en fait les les verts les
consommateurs français sur ce sont des
gens malins
ils chahiri remplissent leurs cuves
quand le prix est bas
je dois dire que quand le en mars en
avril la non mais attendez
avril en avril 2020 quand le baril est
devenu négatif les prix se sont
effondrés on n'a jamais vendu autant de
fioul domestique en abris de bon alors
en ce moment votre est donc en ce moment
je pense que simplement ce qui se passe
c'est que les consommateurs qu'ils
attendent ils attendent en espérant que
le prix va baisser le prix du pétrole a
un peu baissé récemment le prix du soul
alors qu'est ce qui se passe bon d'abord
un ils auront du schmoul
oui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs dans la
sphère russe je vous rappelle que nous
avons très vite pris la position que
nous arrêterions d'importer du pétrole
et des produits pétroliers russes
pourquoi parce que nous avons les moyens
d'assurer leur remplacement à partir
d'autres sources mondial
comprend diesel et fuel domestique
en gros
on est sûrs en europe trois quarts de
notre approvisionnement par le système
de raffinage et pour un quart on dépend
d'importations
la moitié des importations viennent de
russie le reste vient essentiellement du
moyen-orient donc on a
un carrefour et demi un huitième gérer
12% notre système diesel fuel qui vient
de russie et on va s'y substituer tout
manière à partir du 5 février 2023 ne
pourront plus faire appel à ce stade de
notre côté nous avons un terreau nous
interrompt pour au fur et à mesure les
contrats puisqu'on a des contrats d'un
an et au fur et à mesure qu'ils viennent
les chansons les interrompt 12 d'où on
va ramener nous on va ramener le produit
vont à le ramener notamment du
moyen-orient on a les raffineries nous
avons une raffinerie en arabie où on à
la libre disposition des produits que
nous y faisons pour les ramener où nous
voulons donc on donnera priorité à
l'europe et bien sûr à la france ont par
ailleurs dans notre système de trading
et l on est en train de négocier en ce
moment et le prince héritier le pardon
l'émir d'abou dhabi qui vient à paris
lundi on est en train de discuter à
l'eau à la nécessité du gouvernement
français un accord pour pouvoir avoir
accès à du diesel et du fioul venant des
émirats l'hiver prochain si on en a
besoin et total énergie faisant
l'opérateur de cet accord donc on est on
est pleinement mobilisé donc y aura pas
de problème de volume je vous rassure
après le prix le prix c'est les marchés
internationaux et en ce moment ce qui se
passe je vous dire très clairement c'est
ce que je viens de vous écrire sur le
diesel a fait que les primes de diesel
sont partis à un niveau que nous
n'avions jamais connu pourquoi parce que
le système est très tendue et qu' il est
logique que le diesel russes viennent en
europe c'est loin moins possible de
tomber le diesel russe en dehors du
marché européen il faut qu'il aille se
mettre quelque part il va aller se
mettre en un rival se mettre en afrique
qui va aller se mettre en amérique
latine et du coup on va devoir ramener
nous des flux du moyen-orient donc faire
les trajets plus longs et pour l'instant
ce système ne s'étant pas réorganiser le
marché anticipe des difficultés et donc
on a des frites qui sont extrêmement
élevés je vois on a une prime de près de
20 dollars du baril sur du diesel par
rapport au pétrole on n'avait jamais vu
ça dans l'histoire des marchés et ça
c'est un effet direct de la guerre et de
cette disruption imposé par les
sanctions pour des bonnes raisons
politiques mais c est ça qu on fait pas
donc par rapport à votre question les
volumes oui les prix moi je ne suis
malheureux c'est pas nous qui fixons les
prix du tout de ce marché
on est complètement des ronds réplique
les prix des marchés internationaux de
façon on est suivi par tous comme le
lait sur le feu après on se pose dès
qu'on a faits récemment on a pris
plusieurs décisions depuis le mois de
mars on n'a pas attendu même les 18
centimes du gouvernement puisque c'est
nous les premiers qui avons annoncé une
ristourne de 10 centimes sur les
stations rurales on a étendu aux
stations là on a ici faire un effort
supplémentaire à 12 centimes sur les
stations d'autoroutes pourquoi parce que
c'est là qu'il ya beaucoup de français
qui consomment plus je vous rappelle que
par ailleurs dans le réseau access 50 %
de nos ventes d'essence et le diesel en
france on en réseau station access qui
bénéficie en permanence en fait un
rabais de 10 portes de 10 centimes en
permanence donc aller chez access et les
stations d'autoroute au passage sur les
stations d'autoroutes que je note c'est
que notre mouvement entraîner certains
concurrents à nous suivre et que les
français là encore réagissent bien
puisqu'on a vu que les stations sur
autoroute de total energy ont fait on
vendu 20% de plus le premier week-end
que ce qu'elle avait fait l'année
d'aaland on voit bien que le signal prix
voilà ce que je peux vous répondre sur
le fuel par rapport à vos questions
un mot sur ou les lacs la ridt et
monsieur gay sur nos profits vous
l'aurez vous savez on déclare on a on a
des profits
j'ai au clair sur le territoire français
puisque l'impôt il est territorialisées
nous ferons des profits significatifs
cette année sur le raffinage à cause de
ce que je viens de dire après avoir fait
des pères pendant deux ans donc si vous
faire un delta sur la france les a
évidemment et et bien évidemment nous
payerons l'impôt sur ces profils que
nous ferons en france
voilà ce que je peux vous dire bon alors
j'aime pas très bien j'ai pas compris la
question excusez moi la
méga profite je vous dis que si vous
vous demandez si ce que je viens de dire
quand le diesel vaut 25 dollars du baril
de plus 20 dollars du baril peu plus ce
diesel qui l'année dernière il prive qui
était quasi nulle on faisait des pères
d'ailleurs à ce niveau là si vous faites
la différence entre 20 dollars du baril
sur le diesel dans les raffineries les
raffineries françaises et 0 si vous
appelez ça un méga profit oui c'est un
méga profits qui va donner lieu à
l'impôt bien évidemment que nous
paierons après c'est au parlement de
décider quel sera le niveau de niveau 2
de taxation voilà ce que je peux dire
sur sur ces points je vais pas je pense
un point sur co2 nous utilisons l'once
en dollars la tonne tous nos
investissements utilise 100 dollars par
tonne de carbone touche et nous
actualisons le taux d'actualisation de
l'usiné dont dépend des pays pourquoi
parce que c'est dans le taux
actualisation con mais le risque
géopolitique
donc le taux d'actualisation est
beaucoup plus faible en france qu'il ne
l'ait lorsqu'on investit en irak ou dans
un tonneau spiridon quoi le taux
d'actualisation uniforme non c'est pas
comme ça qu'on travaille ni dépens par
contre en général et uniforme sur
l'europe
je dirais l'europe de l'ouest on
applique le même taux mais par contre il
est différenciée selon les pays
madame mcgregor peut-être un mot sur
l'excellente questions sur le marché
européen et son évolution et est ce que
il marche encore donc peut-être
simplement pour dire que c'est vraiment
d'abord un sujet éminemment compliqué
parce que il s'agit de mettre d'accord
quand même 27 pays
moi j'ai une conviction qu'il faut
garder un marché européen que la
robustesse la résilience que nous
garantit le fait d'avoir un réseau
connecté d'ailleurs que ce soit sur le
gazon sur l'électrique est visible
j'allais dire au quotidien des fois nous
exportons d'électricité des fois nous en
importons est pareil sur le gaz donc il
faut arriver à faire évoluer ce marché
mais tout en gardant cette
interconnexion et je pense que c'est
important parce qu'on voit parfois ceux
des failles dans cette unité du marché
européen envoient les pays prenant des
mesures on voit également la décision de
chaque pays chaque état sur son mix
énergétique qui parfois divergences
puisqu'on voit la france qui fait le
choix du nucléaire et à l'allemagne qui
ne fait pas le choix du nucléaire et
voit toute la difficulté bien sûr à
garder les règles donc d'un marché qui
soit allée à la fois cohérent qui
maintient la cohésion de ce marché tout
en prenant en compte bien sur des mix
énergétique très très différents et des
situations très différentes donc c'est
pas un sujet facile nous bien sûr on
peut que le marché doit continuer à
fonctionner de manière libérale mais
avec des mesures par exemple un accès à
des contrats long terme qui permettent
de donner à des clients une meilleure
visibilité sur leurs énergies et
aujourd'hui le marché européen ne le
permet mais de manière assez assez
limité donc toute mesure qui permettrait
à nos clients d'accéder à des contrats
long terme nous paraît effectivement
très importante peut-être un point sur
le carbone en complément de ce qu'a dit
patrick pouyanné pour dire
qu'effectivement on travaille en europe
avec un prix du carbone qui continue
outil qui a qui a quand même pas mal
augmenté par rapport au passé mais pas
complètement à 100 et des juste en
dessous de 100 l'idée quand même c'est
s'assurer que ça devient pas une arme
anticoncurrentielle donc un ajustement
un mécanisme d'ajustement de prix du
carbone aux frontières nous paraît
important pour protéger la compétitivité
bien sûr de nos industries il y avait
également une question importante sur la
sobriété énergétique ce que nous faisons
nous en tant qu énergéticiens pour
développer déployer cette sobriété
énergétique l'augmenter donc trois
grands axes en il ya évidemment tout ce
qui se passe sur autour des campagnes de
la communication on en a un petit peu
parlé je crois tous ensuite c'est sur
les offres les offres pour nos clients
qui doivent donc avoir deux aspects 1
c'est celui du pilotage dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure et puis également et on
teste ça pas mal chez angie de
récompenser alors aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt un système de points mais
récompensé des éco gestes et gestes qui
permettent d'économiser l'énergie on
peut imaginer et ça c'est un travail que
nous devons faire je pense
collectivement de s'assurer que ces
points peuvent être traduits en
avantages monétaires enfin sur les
clients industriels bien sûr c'est tout
ce qui concerne les services de
décarbonation à la fois du conseil mais
aussi
sur le sueur sur les actifs
énergétique de nos clients comment on
peut les rendre bien sûr - moins
gourmands en énergie et ça c'est
extrêmement important et on est très
engagé là-dessus également voilà je
crois que j'ai couvert à peu près les
questions et peut-être
benayoun oui merci donc la première
question à laquelle je souhaiterais
réponse est celle relative à la à la
production de notre de notre parc
nucléaire est ce que ce sera toujours
aussi bas l'hiver prochain donc cette
année effectivement nous aurons une
production comprise entre 280 et 300
térawattheures qui est effectivement
très très basse donc avec une valeur
centrale de 290 l'année prochaine donc
sur l'année 2023 nous visons une
fourchette de 300 330 donc avec une
valeur centrale de 2 313 térawattheures
c'est quand même significativement plus
c'est 25 de plus en espérance et nous
espérons que en 2024 la production va
continuer à augmenter nous sommes
actuellement en discussions avec
l'autorité de sûreté sur le plan de
remédiation à mettre en oeuvre pour
réparer effectivement les conduites qui
sont les conduites il s'utilise qui ont
font l'objet de deux fissures donc oui
le parc nucléaire va revenir
progressivement à une production normale
sur
e
et d'ailleurs juillet pour 22 et 23 ces
données sont très précisément décrite il
y a dans le système électrique pour que
tous les acteurs de marché soient
correctement informés un système qui
s'appellerait mythe par lequel toutes
les indisponibilités prévus doivent être
informés donc on donne la disponibilité
prévue de notre hanche et donc les
valeurs que je vous ai donné pour 22 et
23 sont accessibles à tous et visible de
tous les acteurs sur jp tempo c'est une
très bonne question j pc en fait le
tarif historique à pointe mobile qui a
eu beaucoup de succès puisqu'il ya eu un
million de clients en france qui ont été
des utilisateurs de j p aujourd'hui on
n'est qu'à quatre cent mille parce que
ce tarif est en extinction alors
pourquoi il est en extinction dont on ne
le vend plus il est en extinction parce
que il n'y avait pas de disposition
heures pleines heures creuses et donc ça
veut dire que ces jours là les jours
rouges qui sont au nombre de 22 étaient
des jours très pénalisant pour les
clients donc on l'a remplacé par tempo
tempo c'est simplement le gip et moderne
et un point d'un a déjà deux cent
cinquante mille aujourd'hui et on le
promeut et cette année on espère bien
augmenter significativement le nom mais
effectivement jp n'est plus offert par
ce conte le long le jugeait trop
pénalisant pour les clients sur le prix
du carbone et les prévisions
d'investissement
et les hypothèses que nous faisons pour
nos investissements futurs nous avons ce
que nous faisons c'est nous prenons en
compte en fait le risque industriel sur
chaque catégorie d'investissement et
nous pensons effectivement que les
investissements dans des technologies
carbonées sont plus risqués donc c'est
pour ça qu'on les affects d'une prime de
risque un peu supérieure donc nous avons
bien pris ça en compte mais sur la
question du prix du carbone c'est un
sujet éminemment politique je me
prononcerai pas je dirais simplement que
ce qui est un peu gênant c'est l'absence
de stabilité sur ce sujet dire que pour
que le prix du carbone soit un signal
efficace pour la décarbonation il faut
une politique qui soit constante or on
voit bien dans tous les pays d'europe
que tout le monde joue avec cette idée
mais entre les industriels l'émisssion
tradingscreen pour les grands les petits
la taxe générale sur les activités
polluantes il y a beaucoup de mouvements
et beaucoup d'allers retours donc je
crois qu'effectivement il faut qu'on
aille vers une politique de tarification
du carbone qu'ils soient plus durable
qu'ils soient plus robuste et qui
permettent à tous les acteurs d'investir
en fonction de cette politique et enfin
sur le marché européen d'énergie je
partage tout à fait ce qui a été dit par
madame mcgregor le marché aujourd'hui et
est à des niveaux de volatilité
totalement totalement incroyable on a
besoin d'un marché pour le système
électrique sert d'un système de dispatch
européen qui valorise les
interconnexions et donc ce qu'on appelle
aussi le market coupling donc on ne peut
pas quitter le marché mais ce que le
marché de l'électricité le marché de
gros cela étant ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que le prix actuel est un système
dans lequel le prix du gaz qui est très
élevé pour les raisons que vous avez
tous comprise contamine le marché de
l'électricité et donc là on a une
difficulté qui va falloir traiter même
l'europe qui étaient contre à des
propositions qui ont été faites et porté
par eurelectric commence à dire oui à
ces niveaux de prix ça veut plus rien
dire c'est absolument insupportable
les rangs infra marginales sont
colossales et c'est donc il ya des
acteurs qui s'enrichissent beaucoup
d'autres à quissac beaucoup trop
d'argent voilà pour vous donner quelques
chiffres assez intéressant le système un
système électrique qui repose sur trois
types d'actifs des actifs de base des
actifs de semi base des actifs de pointe
et tout ça est valorisé en fonction de
la centrale marginal appelé est
effectivement plus en est à la pointe et
plus c'est cher mais pour que ce système
fonctionne
il faut qu'il y ait un certain équilibre
entre le prix de la pointe et le prix de
la base donc ça marche très bien ça
quand le prix du gaz est à 15 20 25
euros quand le prix du gaz est à 100
euros et que donc le barème de la pointe
est à 300 ce système ne fonctionne plus
donc effectivement le marché européen de
l'énergie aujourd'hui de l'électricité
et du gaz il pose problème l'europe le
reconnaît et il faudra sans doute
réfléchir à des hommes à des amendements
à ce marché juste ajouter quelque chose
pourquoi ils marchent pas le marché du
gaz parce qu'en fait on a construit un
marché gazier en considérant que le gaz
russe était de gaz domestique européen
l'erreur qui est fait et notre pays vous
notre grand voisin allemand le pal payé
durement c'est que en fait on a 40% de
production domestique que dans la
norvège la mer du nord le gaz russe
représente et 30 à 40 % donc concevoir à
marché est un marché qui est
complètement spot enfin qui est
complètement aujourd'hui au jour le jour
quand on possède comme aux états unis on
met on est maître de sa production ça
marche quand on se met à dépendre
profondément l'ex ranger et ben en plus
on se découvre qu'il ne manque de
capacité de stockage eh ben ça marche
pas et la réponse qu'on fait les pays
asiatiques notamment le japon maintenant
la chine également depuis 25 ans c'est
qu'en fait ils ont décidé pour que ça
marche leur marché gazzin de mettre des
contrats à moyen et long terme nous
vendons aujourd'hui
nous le guetteur du gaz naturel liquéfié
je vends du gnl au japon et au qatar
beaucoup moins cher qu'aujourd'hui en
europe parce qu'ils ont accepté de
signer des contrats de 20 ou 25 ans que
ces contrats clal durée évidemment paix
en échange de la longueur de la durée
qu'il permet d'investir ils ont des
formules de prix liées au pétrole avec
des engrais des planchers déplaçons pour
être alors les plafonds bouge un peu
mais en gros est donc aujourd'hui quand
je regarde combien je vends le mont prix
moyen à ces pays asiatiques est en gros
des autres autour de 13 $ pavillon bt eu
disons 80 dollars du baril qu'en est il
aujourd'hui enfants en europe qui est un
marché complètement au jour le jour eh
ben on est à 200 dollars donc le choix
que doit faire l'europe maintenant c'est
pas un problème
le marché unique c'est d'accepter que
l'on puisse commettre à moyen et long
terme que les acteurs puissent le faire
elle est réellement ça ça pose un vrai
problème par rapport à la stratégie
climatique parce que il faut trouver des
acteurs européens qui acceptent de
signer des contrats long terme gazier
donc ils bénéficieront de ce prix il
faut un horizon pour le faire pourquoi
il manque des terminaux de
regazéification en europe pourquoi mais
parce qu'en fait on écoute on vous
écoute les leaders politiques dont vous
dites on veut sortir du gaz en europe
pourquoi voulez vous qu'on allait
investir dans des terminaux de
regazéification en europe qui ont amorti
sur 20 ou 25 ans il me faut 20 ans pour
l'amortir un terminal de regazéification
lithiques du lit qu'on va sortir du gaz
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'en ce moment
nous on a même des terminaux flottant on
amène des terminaux flottant parce que
comme il flotte pas je vais les
installer au havre pendant cinq ans ou
en allemagne et puis le jour où l'europe
il dira je veux plus ce gaz on les
ramènera où ils sont d'ailleurs rien
d'inquiétant chine on est en train de
prendre de la chine pour le ramener en
europe on le ramènera là où il a leur a
besoin donc donc on écoute les signaux
politiques et donc le marché c'est pas
pour moi là la théorie du prix au coût
marginal elle marchait plutôt que
l'injection dans les marchés du gaz
aujourd'hui est pas raisonnable parce
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas à ses
producteurs ont des prend l'extérieur et
en fait on la russie n'est pas en europe
voilà ce qu'on est en train de découvrir
notre commission
est particulièrement sensible parce
qu'un homme de rapports que nous avons
rendu à l'unanimité ici était tout à
fait dans ce sens là je demande je donne
la parole à quatre ok je vous demandais
mes chers collègues une forme de
sobriété non pas énergétique mais mais
de la parole dominique estrosi reçues
pierre clippers
merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs j'aimerais vous poser quelques
questions sur les logements puisque vous
l'avez dit nous le savons tous le
logement est déterminant pour réduire la
consommation d'énergie pour les
logements neufs devraient savoir ce que
vous pensez de la m e 20 20 et est elle
aujourd'hui toujours adapté pendant deux
tenu du contexte de crise pour les
logements existants
que pensez-vous du dpe diagnostic de
performance énergétique et sa
méthodologie est elle suffisamment
calibré et bien calibrés et puis pour
revenir sur deux questions qu'a évoquée
daniel grémillet pensez vous que les
dispositifs de soutien publics sont
suffisants je pense bien sûr en
particulier à ma prime rénove je
rappellerai juste quelques chiffres en
2021 seuls 126 primes ont été versées à
des propriétaires bailleurs
et 69 à des copropriétaires ce qui
représente 0,5 et 0,01 pour cent du
total des primes versées donc on voit
bien que ce dispositif ma prime rénove
n'est pas à la hauteur d'une
massification comme on devrait la
connaître dans notre pays et donc ne
pensez vous pas qu'il faille agir
d'urgence enfin les dispositifs décédé e
alors pour perd donc être redondant
reste a dit daniel aurait simplement
savoir si les cas de fraude ont
aujourd'hui été résolu et pierre
clippers ensuite daniel salmon oui merci
madame la présidente si vous le
permettez de questions courtes pour
décarbonés relocaliser la production
d'hydrocarbures
monsieur pouyanne est nous pouvons
développer le biogaz et les
biocarburants vous l'avez évoqué plus
tard dans le cadre de la planification
que vous souhaitez sur la transition
nous savons tous que la france dispose
d'atouts importants sur ces deux points
précis en raison de sa tradition
agricole je dirais historique pour
autant l'essor du biogaz est entravée
par un objectif de production de 10%
d'ici 2030 et les biocarburants par un
objectif d'incorporation lui de 7% à la
même date je sais qu'on est un petit peu
au dessus actuellement nous savons qu'il
est possible de faire un peu plus bien
sûr sans générer bien sûr de conflits
d'usagé tant sur le fond c'est que sur
les prix agricoles que sur la
disponibilité des matières premières
aussi faut-il revoir ses objectifs nous
pouvons et devons le faire dans la loi
quinquennale sur l'énergie de 2023 pour
le premier et la révision de la
directive européenne sur les énergies
renouvelables en 2026 pour le second à
très court terme ne peut-on pas
débloquer les projets de biogaz en
attente et favoriser les technologies de
conversion et d'approvisionnement en
biocarburants c'était ma peau question
la deuxième question sur une remarque
très courte vous avez tous ses voeux
évoqué la sobriété et je vous ai
entendus les uns ou les autres sur les
ondes ya quelques semaines dire qu'il
fallait savoir éteindre ses lumières
quand on n'était pas dans la pièce etc
et faire des économies tente on allait
manquer d'énergie électrique pour
l'hiver prochain et qu'il fallait être
prudent alors comment comprendre qu'en
2035 la commission européenne a décidé
qu'il n'y aurait plus de moteurs
thermiques et qu'il fallait passer et la
france soutient cette position au tout
électrique j'ai du mal à comprendre ce
paradoxe merci messieurs et mesdames et
messieurs de me l'expliquer clairement
merci daniel salmon ensuite laurent du
plan merci madame la présidente madame
messieurs
je partage votre alerte sur sur ce qui
va se passer cet hiver je suis ravi de
vous entendre parler de sobriété puisque
je défends ça depuis des dizaines
d'années nous luttons contre le
gaspillage organisé parce qu'on peut
dire que ça a été organisé pendant un
certain temps et donc il faut
effectivement s'employer à une forme de
décroissance des consommations au jour
viendrait brièvement sur la rénovation
thermique effectivement nous ne sommes
pas dans la trajectoire puisque l'année
dernière nous n'avons eu que 2500
rénovation globale là où on vous devrez
en attendre sept cent mille il faut
vraiment là s'employer à résoudre ce
problème des urgences va des passoires
thermiques parce que on ne peut pas
demander à ceux qui ont déjà deux pulls
d'en mettre un troisième je pense que ce
sont peut-être certaines élites qui
devrait me donner l'exemple et met
elle-même le pull donc j'en appelle au
sénat l'hiver prochain à baisser la
température de quelques degrés et
peut-être de mettre des pulls parce que
c'est l'isolation la plus rapprochée je
sais bien
voilà la question est bien qu est ce que
vous pensez donc de ma prime rénove qui
aujourd'hui n'apporte pas les solutions
qui sont à la hauteur à la hauteur des
enjeux concernant les énergies
renouvelables je suis ravie aussi de
voir que voulez vous les portez
aujourd'hui il faut les porter beaucoup
plus fort et faire en sorte que la
contestation sur l'éolien terrestre ne
soit pas également une contestation
organisée donc je pense qu'il va falloir
s'employer à cela pour effectivement
redorer le blason de l'éolien je pense
que l'énergie par contre c'est un point
de désaccord je pense que l'énergie doit
être à la hauteur du prix qu'il convient
l'énergie pas cher a amené le gaspillage
je pense que là c'est plutôt une
question de revenus qui est à mettre en
question mais non pas le coût de
l'énergie en elle-même
merci beaucoup à daniel laurent duplomb
dans la sobriété
merci madame la présidente je sais pas
si je vais être dans la sobriété mais je
voudrais revenir sur des points très
précis qui correspond à ce que j'entends
sur le terrain depuis deux mois de façon
récurrente la première question c'est
par rapport au prix de l'électricité
pour tous ceux qui ne sont pas aux
tarifs réglementés et qui m'alerte pour
leur entreprise sur les évolutions qui
vont être colossal je vous prends trois
exemples le groupe aurea sur la loire et
la haute loire qui va passer de 1,7
million d'euros en 2021 à 5,4 millions
entre 23 et 24 la société al trium qui
traite les ordures ménagères de tout le
département de la haute-loire qui me dit
pas c'est 210 mille euros à 750 milles
euros une scierie sur le département de
la haute-loire aussi qui va passer à 2
500 mille euros en 2021 à 2,7 millions
en 2023 qui peut croire dans notre pays
que les marges bénéficiaires de ces
entreprises puissent absorber ces
évolutions aussi rapide et aussi
importante de l'électricité deuxième
point j'étais en visite du barrage de
poutès dans la haute loire qui a subi
les foudres du des demandes écologistes
donc qui a fait qu'on a rasé le mur du
barrage pour nos turbines et que de
l'eau en constant c'est-à-dire 38 kub or
constamment la problématique qu'on me
dit à la visite de ce barrage c'est que
la réalité de ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a une capacité de
production d'électricité
certes qui est assez bonne avec nos
centrales nucléaires mais là on risque
d'avoir un problème ce qui explique
pourquoi le gouvernement a été obligé de
revenir sur une idée de fermeture des
centrales thermiques celle épique c'est
à dire les pointes de consommation
d'électricité qui nous demande de
produire plus d'électricité à un moment
donné là seules pour lucy possibilité
mon qui n'y connaît rien ou on
m'explique que pour faire face à ces
pics il ya deux solutions c'est soit les
barrages hydroélectriques sur lesquels
on peut faire varier le turbinage c'est
à dire la capacité de produire
l'électricité en turbines en plus ou en
turbines à moins donc surtout pas le
barrage de poutès puisqu'on a effacé le
mur mais aussi les centrales thermiques
à gaz ou à charbon on me dit aussi que
ces pics on a rien de prévu pour les
améliorer avec question elle est toute
simple qu'en penseront nous en france
recréer la possibilité d'avoir des
projets de barrages hydroélectriques
pour permettre cette évolution sur les
pics sinon nous serons condamnés pour
traiter ces pics à réouvrir des
centrales thermiques à charbon et à gaz
et enfin ma dernière question concerne
le gaz on nous dit j'ai reçu le
directeur régional d'énergie pas plus
tard qu'avant-hier surnom département
qui me dit que l'évolution du gaz va
passer par la méthanisation
ok peut-être c'est peut-être une bonne
chose mais quand pensez vous que sur ces
énergies renouvelables on ait la
possibilité enfin d'avoir une
réévaluation du tarif de rachat de
l'électricité ou du gaz en fonction de
l'évolution des prix parce que ça c'est
pas prévu donc à un agriculteur qui a
une mécanisation et qui voit
l'augmentation du prix du gasoil pour
faire les cultures ne voit pas dans le
même temps le prix de l'augmentation de
l'électricité ou du gaz qu'il vend à un
fournisseur parce que c'est un contrat
sur 20 ans guy lefrand pas merci laurent
voilà madame magritte gants peut-être
simplement pour dire c'est que c'est
vrai que la r 20 et en général je pense
que
il ya eu à un moment une vue que l'on
pouvait accélérer la disparition du gaz
en france je veux juste rappeler un
chiffre un soir d'hiver en france le
réseau gazier fournit l'équivalent de
1,3 à 1,5
la puissance électrique installée
la france s'engage ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudrait plus que doublé
l'infrastructure électrique existante
aujourd'hui ce n'est juste pas
raisonnable donc en fait nous avons
regretté un chai ndjila et revin qui en
fait fais comme si final assez vite on
va pouvoir se passer du gaz moi je pense
que c'est une erreur on va avoir besoin
du gaz pendant très longtemps c'est un
composant important de la transition
énergétique
d'ailleurs c'est reconnu maintenant
taxonomie alors bien sûr il faut
travailler sur le contenu carbone de ce
gaz donc là je vous rejoins monsieur le
biométhane en france on a un potentiel
qui est très important on pense qu'il
peut être révisée à la hausse moi mes
discussions avec les gouvernements sont
plutôt constructif ce sujet et donc je
j'invite bien sûr
l'assemblée à soutenir tout ce qui peut
permettre d'accélérer tous les sujets de
permis et d'autorisation de ces de ces
projets il y en a pas mal qui sont dans
les tuyaux et je pense qu'on peut
avancer à relativement court terme en
plus parce que c'est assez aujourd'hui
bien sûr il faut les faire de manière
responsable vous avez raison bien
respecté les pourcentages de production
agricole des productions destinées au
biométhane et au biogaz mais je pense
que c'est très vertueux la france a de
la chance on est en avance on qu'il faut
y aller voilà donc sur petite réponse
sur le gaz à la fois sur le biométhane
et cela est revin
bien sûr le logement juste un
commentaire je pense que comme vous
l'avez divin pour être copropriétaire
j'évolue avec mes collègues au bruit
était à utiliser ma prime raynaud c'est
trop compliqué c'est beaucoup trop
compliqué et je trouve que total énergie
en gère puisque j'ai des équipes chez
moi qui gère des c2
c'est je pense que je serai pas
intervenu je sais pas si on aurait il
aurait vu la couleur de la prime je
pense qu'il faut qu'on simplifie ses
systèmes il ya on est dans un système
administratif où on n'a pas confiance
les uns dans les autres noms de la
fraude est donc à partir de là on
demande des papiers et si vous n'avez
pas envoyé peu de papier trois jours
avant dix jours avant on vous explique
que vous êtes deux jours trop tard et
qu'il faut que le devis sous h pourquoi
c'est trop compliqué il faut qu'on
simplifie ses systèmes là c'est comme
pour les bornes de recharge je vais voir
le président les bornes de recharge en
france on donne les subventions pour les
déployer simplement il ya quatre guichet
différent et on a peur que total energy
2 buts ne construisent pas la borne
alors effectivement je voulais qu'on
peut les contrôler mais bon je peux
prendre des photos dont je pense qu'il
ya un sujet de simplification je pense
que c'est un bon dispositif qu'il faut
l'accélérer mais il faut le simplifier
se mettre à la place des utilisateurs et
pas simplement d'avoir au nom de la
fraude on contrôle trop et on n'y arrive
pas l'essai de jeu je suis c'est un
outil administrés il faut faire
attention aux outils administrés c'est
pas la même chose que ma prime rénove ce
n'est pas une subvention directe à la
personne qui fait les travaux c'est un
système administratif très intelligent
simplement qui a plein de grippe là de
l'un d'eux et qui peut naturellement
donné lieu à que je dirais des systèmes
qui donne des points de ses deux yeux
qu'ils soient pas aussi efficace que ce
qu'on voudrait c'est pas la meilleure
façon de faire des économies d'énergie
il faut faire attention à mon avis à
vouloir étendre encore plus si la
réponse c'est ont doublé ces deux pour
faire des copies cassitérite j'ai peur
qu'on n'est pas l'efficacité énergétique
par contre je rappelle les c2 à la fin
écoutant france à peu près 5 milliards
d'euros par an j'en prends 20 % edf 30
simplement c'est pas moi qui les gardent
il repart sur les consommateurs
aujourd'hui les ces deux fautes 6
centimes dans le prix de l'essence coûte
5 euros du mégawattheures dans le prix
de l'électricité et du gaz en gros donc
c'est un système qui tourne c'est pas
une taxe c'est un système donc moi je
pense qu'il vaut mieux aider les gens
qui font des travaux directement que
dans les scènes trop administrés voilà
pour le pour le logement
un point que je voulais répondre
attendez je vais voter biogaz de gaz
enfin juste un point il faut que oui on
a besoin potentiel de biogaz plus
important la question c'est qu'il faut
que nos acteurs que nous on soit
raisonnable soit on demande à l'état de
nous garantir un tarif
il nous garantit un tarif dire à l'état
bunga c'est ton cocon fait un
investissement on a pas de risque
j'investis dans un méthaniseur j'ai un
tarif à 90 euros ou 100 euros du
mégawatt il va me le payer quel que soit
le prix quand le prix du gaz était l'an
dernier à 30 ou 40 euros je recevais 90
euros donc il faut qu'on soit tous
raisonnable soit on a une garantie et
c'est un assurance et quand le prix
monte va on envoyait déficit pas donc
c'est un choix moi en ce moment je suis
en train de demander à mes équipes
puisque on a 10% des bureaux méthaniseur
français est ce qu'on doit rester dans
le tarif régulé où est ce que je dois
racheter mon tarif et me mettre dans le
marché libre prendre une part de risque
libre mais je pense qu'on peut pas
demander si vous permet je suis pas
l'état à la fois à l'état d'assurer une
garantie et puis quand ça nous arrange
danseurs de de prendre le surplus donc
aujourd'hui par contre
je suis d'accord donc moi je pense qu'il
faut libérer les volumes et puis après
est aujourd'hui un acteur comme total
énergie on a une réunion la semaine
dernière j'ai demandé à mes collègues de
lancer des constructions de méthaniseur
en prenant une partie du risque sans
demander la garantie de l'état sur tout
le volume et on va libérer de
l'investissement mais il faut que chacun
des acteurs dans cette affaire soit soit
cohérent su me permettre parce que sinon
on va demander à l'état tous financés à
la fin c'est quand même nos impôts qui
financent ne faut pas c'est tout ça ça
va pas donc voilà maintenant il ya un
vrai potentiel qu'il faut libérer y
compris heures je peux vous le dire vrai
obstacle aujourd'hui comme cela c'est
les procédures moi j'ai découvert ce
monde du biométhane en rachetant la
compagnie fonroche j'ai passé une
journée à agen mais c'est c'est
diabolique enfin vous vous ne vous
rendez pas les efforts que font des
équipes pour faire une c'est fait pour
il faut mettre un nombre d'autorisations
sais je sais bien qu'il ya des aveugles
or c'est dommage parce que c'est une
énergie totalement locale qui créent des
emplois locaux et donc il ya un vrai
potentiel dans notre pays c'est
l'économie circulaire à le biométhane
isr ça fait les odeurs mais cic gérable
c'est moins moche qu'une éolienne voilà
donc en tout cas on est favorable mais
il faut donc il faut oui dans la
prochaine ppe il faut libérer les
volumes après à l'état d'arbitrer entre
tarifs garanties et tarifs - garantie
c'est aujourd'hui le tarif serait pas
garantie les biocatalyseurs
effectivement gagner de l'argent mais on
peut pas le beurre et l'argent du beurre
si je puis me permettre dans cette
affaire il vit mal écrit électrique je
pense carlos tavares a tout dit je pense
que cette affaire c'est un problème de
poule et d'oeuf maintenant qu'on a
décidé que les véhicules électriques
devait venir il faut qu'on déploie les
les bornes de recharge roval faire il
faut bien évidemment que les réseaux
électriques suivent et que les moyens
électrique suivent
je sais pas parce qu'on va prendre des
mesures et donc et une incitation très
forte à investir maintenant à faire les
investissements en tout cas c'est comme
ça que le prend on attendait le signal
maintenant qu'on a le signal on va
investir lourdement il faut il nous faut
l'électricité mais pour la transition
énergétique la transition énergétique
s'est profondément de l'électricité
décarbonés profondément donc il faut que
les réacteurs nucléaires d'edf soit
l'heure en 2035 et pas de papa si cela
vaut peut-être beaucoup plus
merci merci patrick pour cette
déclaration
donc effectivement je voudrais commencer
par le parent ce sujet convient
d'évoquer quand même rappeler qu'il n'ya
pas eu de black out en france depuis
1978 et que même si on est dans une
situation très difficile il ya quand
même des très fortes chances que nous
passions l'hiver sans délestage il y a
si les stocks de gaz sont normalement
rempli et il sait se présente bien il
faut savoir que les températures de
déclenchement c'est à dire celle qui
amène le système électrique à des
puissances appelées normes et à des
risques sont quand même de -4 degrés
pendant plusieurs jours l'année dernière
on a eu une une vague de froid de ce
type coup de chance c'était au entre
noël et le jour de l'an à un moment où
la consommation était faible et donc il
n'y a eu aucun problème donc je pense
que dire que l'on va vers une situation
catastrophique et qu'on va manquer
d'électricité personnellement je ne le
crois pas et justement comme vient de le
dire patrick le gouvernement a pris des
décisions pour qu'on investisse à
nouveau dans le nucléaire au delà du
fait qu'on va revenir à une production
normale oui mais vous savez c'est pas le
rythme d'augmentation de pénétration des
véhicules électriques ça représente même
pas 1% des de la demande électrique
cette année 1 il ya un point aussi que
peut-être que vous ne savez pas monsieur
mais c'est que la consommation en
énergie d'un véhicule thermique et et
est beaucoup plus faible que celle d'un
véhicule d'un véhicule électrique que
scénariste thermique à ce que le
rendement est bien meilleure donc quand
on regarde les prévisions de coûts
d'appels de puissance sur le système
électrique au titre des véhicules
électriques c'est pas du tout
considérable ces 10-15 % donc penser que
d'ici 2035 avec les investissements qui
sont faits dans le nucléaire et dans le
renouvelable on n'arrivera pas à
augmenter notre potentiel de production
de 10 15% ce serait extrêmement
défaitiste donc nous pensions qu'il est
tout à fait possible mais après il y à
la question des comportements et du
changement comme comme cela vient d'être
dit c'est pas évident d'amener tous les
français à changer leur véhicule leurs
habitudes la façon dont il se recharge
et ça c'est un travail de c'est un
travail de longue haleine sur
le logement alors que sur le logement
madame effectivement c'est une question
très importante c'est un domaine qui
reste très émissifs en france avec
beaucoup de co2 émis pour deux raisons
d'une part parce qu'on utilise en cours
trop de fossiles dans le chauffage et on
nous pensons que il ya des solutions
modernes la pompe à chaleur est une très
bonne solution est par ailleurs on doit
faire mieux aussi pour développer
l'isolation et l'amélioration de la
qualité sur ce sujet c'est vrai qu'à une
pléthore de dispositifs et de procédures
entre les c2 les c2 de précarité le fond
logement ma prime rénove ça reste quand
même un petit peu difficile à lire pour
les clients et je pense que même si le
gouvernement a fait des progrès on n'est
pas encore sur ce sujet à un niveau de
grande simplicité et quant aux c2e c'est
vrai ça coûte aux français quand même 5
milliards ça finances en fait des
travaux tous les français financent des
travaux qui sont faits chez quelques-uns
qui bénéficient de ces deux et donc
effectivement c'est un c'est un canal de
financement qui a pu occasionner des
fraudes moi ce que je constate
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya certainement
moins de fraudes mais il ya quand même
le sujet de l'efficacité insuffisante de
certains gestes c'est à dire qu'on
finance au nom de l'efficacité
énergétique des travaux ça améliore
l'habitat mais cela ne réduit pas la
consommation donc effectivement ces
vertueux dans la mesure où ça soutient
l'emploi ça soutient des artisans qui
font les travaux mais sur le plan
d'efficacité énergétique le l'efficacité
n'est pas complètement encore démontré
ou alors mes chers collègues j'étais en
train de vous envoyer un message parce
que ce rendez vous à cette audition de
ce matin est un miracle de voilà de
d'organisation pour avoir nos trois
énergéticien en même temps par contre je
m'étais engagé à terminer
7000 cette commission à 10 heures pour
des obligations des uns et des autres
conseils d'administration rendez vous et
c'est donc il y a encore beaucoup
d'inscrits et donc beaucoup de questions
donc je vous propose à tous les trois
que ces questions vous soit envoyée par
écrit je suis désolé de voilà de couper
cette cette audition il y avait encore
beaucoup de questions oui jean marc
patricia avons tous moi je voudrais vous
remercier beaucoup tous les trois de la
voir pour vous reviendrez vous
reviendrez aux jurés
de toute façon je pense qu'on aura des
questions très importantes sur le
devenir de df n'est ce pas monsieur
benayoun qui va nous et que nous occupe
et je pense dans les mois qui viennent
mais aussi sur les questions
énergétiques que les uns et les autres
plus en profondeur donc merci beaucoup
de cette première audition qui faisait
suite à votre tribune et merci à mes
collègues de leur bienveillance et il
nous faire passer les questions on
enverra un tir groupé de deux questions
s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup